hi there today i'm going to talk about
uh my uh engagement with tim young has
fascinating
podcast
and briefly about the media and
information wars and the situation in
ukraine
uh so before i get to kim yong-ha
uh let me just say that i had some
requests from some of my viewers who are
from russian who's therefore whose
native language is not english asking me
to produce subtitles in russian
i am terribly sorry i'm not going to do
that
i often get requests when i do a video
in a language other than english
from people saying could you please put
up subtitles in english or translate
it's just too much work i don't have the
time you know my time is my own
uh i'm semi-retired but i have so many
things that i want to do i'm just not
going to spend the time to translate or
to create subtitles for these videos i
am terribly sorry i try to speak clearly
so that people whose native language is
not english will have a chance to kind
of try to understand when i read when i
listen or read something in another
language i don't ask for subtitles i try
to
get you know download that audio content
uh in in the case of korean kim
jung-ha's
podcast i actually paid someone to
provide a transcript so that i can study
and learn from it i've done that for
romanian in the past
um
i should add that the kumyung has
podcast is going into our library at
link
so yeah i mean this podcast
or this
youtube space is about learning
languages i'm sorry
if i had unlimited resources i would
provide you with subtitles it's just not
gonna happen sorry
uh with regard to some of the comments
from some russians and they were
supported with you know thumbs up
uh to the effect that you know i
shouldn't uh i shouldn't listen to some
of the sort of uh independent news
sources in russia like canal dosht which
which has now been shut down
uh
and that i should listen to uh
what's it called the voice of russia or
whatever it's called
um
let me just say that i have nothing but
the utmost respect for the independent
media in russia i think they are very
courageous i think it's very courageous
to be considered a traitor and i think
one of the comments was that
can aldoste are traitors and they lie
i think that's extremely important in
russia today
according to a survey that i heard 70 or
80 percent of the people if not more
support the government
in what they're doing in the crimean
and so to stand up at that time and say
no i don't think that's correct takes a
lot of courage it's not unlike the
situation when george bush the younger
invaded iraq
uh and there was like 60 70 support in
the u.s and apparently the media also
was like according to one survey 70 of
the media was
pro-iraq now to be fair george bush was
a little smarter than putin because he
managed to get 20 countries alongside
unfortunately for russia they've got
nobody alongside not even kazakhstan
however principle is the same lots of
euphoria support media support media in
the united states was influenced by the
whatever information they were fed by
the us military us government
however
a year or two later a majority of
americans thought the war was a mistake
and a majority of the media had turned
against the war but the difficult thing
is to be against these kinds of actions
to
suggest you know different points of
view let's consider what we're doing to
do that at a time of this sort of
national euphoria uh again i was
listening to echo escape they
interviewed the
a russian who is the editor or the local
representative for the economist and he
was reminding us that in 1914 the
support for russia's involvement in the
first world war was even higher than it
is today
and yet this euphoria passed fairly
quickly so who knows what's going to
happen but i support and i think the
fact that in russia they are closing
down independent media is very
unfortunate for russia because i know
that journalists are just as incompetent
as any other group
of people you find incompetence
everywhere and whenever i read an
article about something that i'm very
familiar with i realize just how poorly
informed or how prejudiced
the reporter often is but the greater
the variety of news sources the better
so for example the american media might
have been 70 in favor of george bush in
whenever it was 2003 but the british
media was not for example or the french
media or the spanish media so the
greater the variety of media sources
that you can access the more likely
you're going to get
some sense of what's really happening so
i just want to
comment you know don't tell me that
canal dodged is a is a traitor
unpatriotic lie i don't buy it i don't
buy it they may not be right they may be
inaccurate
any
news source can be inaccurate can be
biased therefore you need a variety of
news sources and what's happening in
russia today is that everything is
controlled by the government and
news and information has become uh a
weapon in in a sort of a virtual war so
i consider that very unfortunate i'm
sorry if that annoys my russian uh
listeners they have a different opinion
they're welcome to express the opinion
here in their comments
getting back to kim yoha
it's a fascinating podcast because he
talks about reading he talks about
the interchange between authors and
their readers he talks about a
particular book which was meant to be
read out loud which was more common some
centuries ago that only a few people
could read so books were read out loud
to other people he talks about uh
podcasts how it enables him to
communicate sort of asynchronously
asynchronously with people in different
parts of the world different time zones
from his living room to say my living
room as a canadian study in korean and
and so all of these things and then the
books he talks about and not just korean
books but
japanese books
french russian
uh to me it's just fascinating so while
i i have trouble understanding it and
i'm picking my way through it
um
it's like this treasure trove that i
know is there for me and it's just a
matter of me fighting my way through it
uh and learning the words and phrases as
i as i get into what you know he is is
sharing with us
and i know that having now discovered
this very interesting uh uh
content and i know there's more similar
interesting content in korea from
koreans on different subjects that
korean you know i i i won't stop uh my
engagement with korean at the end of my
90 day challenge it's something that
will be with me and i will continue to
be able to enjoy an engagement with
korean just as i enjoy my engagement
with russian french chinese japanese you
name it
so